so why did you choose this topic well
I've been watching roads must fall from
Oxford with interest when I was Oxford I
did a paper on post-colonial studies and
Africa in the era of decolonization and
it always struck me as remarkable that
the building I would go to to find the
dusty Africa journals was very proud and
it's not you know just a statue of
Rhodes there's a whole building named
lost rose he funded it you know and it
was kind of the center for the Rhodes
Scholars and Africa in the Commonwealth
and I just thought it was fascinating
that that was the place that if he
wanted to study the legacy of empire and
colonialism and the kind of struggle for
independence of these countries you know
you have to go to his shrine sit in his
kind of temple and there are paintings
and statues from everywhere and you know
and among the Rhodes Scholars who tended
to be the other people studying this
stuff and I just thought the whole
architecture of his legacy with
complicated and really interesting so
when Rhodes must fall all these years
later because in my time I don't feel
like there was the confidence among
students who had the same kind of
feelings as I did we didn't come
together there was no social media there
was no kind of movement we all just kind
of talked about it quietly and in a kind
of you know slightly embittered way so I
thought it was fascinating to see this
movement grow up and these students now
marching the streets demonstrating
organizing campaigning starting
petitions you know demanding that this
be addressed so that's what first got my
interest in it and it's an it's spread
obviously because it's been going on in
South Africa it's become a major issue
in the state and I think the specific
issue of the colonial legacy in
education okay but if it okay let's so I
used to go to Rhodes house mostly to
sleep it was really nice and cozy
yeah yeah it had nice big chairs you
could just have a Kip in pretend to work
but the I was aware of the irony yeah I
mean I think that what's getting lost in
this debate first of all I wonder and
I'm going to subject you to a few
questions
who was settled Rhodes right do you know
why he's a hate figure do you yeah what
what is his biggest crime genocide of
people indigenous people in southern
Africa
I mean removal a bit vague it was the
matter belly by their introduction of
blankets laced with smallpox the famous
thing that is a largely apocryphal done
to the North American indigenous
population was done to the matter viele
population in what is now southern
Zimbabwe by roads in the metropolis
hills and around Bulawayo that first of
all second that wasn't that wasn't that
was the genocide secondly he did deals
with particularly with the matter
feeling he was very keen he was
convinced there was going to be gold in
that region and subsequently there has
been discovered diamonds stab them in
the back classic colonial stuff right an
absolute engine of commercial expansion
and imperialist par excellence and by
any definition a genocide almera right
with a racist white supremacist ideal
which wasn't that unusual at the time
but he wasn't a massive racist in the in
the Hitlerian
sense of the word he didn't kill people
because in which white people in ya know
the three C civilization Christianity
and commerce being the big driving
factor so I'm not defending the guy what
I find and nothing that you've just said
about him thanks any less ironic to me
that in order to study the legacy of
empire the first thing is is to I think
to understand who he is when people are
marching the roads must fall all that
kind of stuff are they aware I mean I
find it a delicious irony the the legacy
of Rhodes really the enduring legacy of
Rhodes now thank God Rhodesia the white
supremacy in Rhodesia no longer exists
but the only thing that remains really
is a rather lovely building some
comfortable chairs and a an
international scholarship for whom the
principal beneficiaries are the sons and
daughters of the colonial descendants of
people like Cecil Rhodes who are now
campaigning no doubt for the removal of
his statue and so on
case of Sam I think and I'm you know I'm
not in any way saying that I I wished
the road scholarship program didn't
exist but the problem with this is it's
not ancient history so okay white
supremacy is not no longer the official
regime in Zambia and Zimbabwe but it's
not that long ago it's in my lifetime
that Ian Smith was still the premier and
when I was at Oxford I had friends who
were Road scholars and I made friends
with a white South African guy who was a
Rhodes Scholar we were both in PPE we
studied in the library together really
nice I we just really got along he
invited me to his birthday drinks one
summer at a pub by the river and I went
down there and it was one of just it was
one of my university experiences that
really stands out because I had lots of
friends who were Rhodes and Marshall
scholars and you know they were all over
the world and they were all braces and I
went to this white South Africans Rhodes
Scholars drinks and I got there and it
was literally you know those scenes and
those westerns where someone enters a
saloon and you could hear a pin drop
that was the whole place went silent
literally and it was the most
uncomfortable moment of my university
life and I realized when I looked at
them it was all the white road scholars
literally there was not a single black
road scholar there was not a single
black person and that's why when I came
in it was almost like I'd broken this
unspoken rule which I was completely
oblivious of he was just my friend and
from that I got more of an awareness
that even within the road scheme that
legacy of racism and separation and
insecurity and Prejudice than you know
and all of these things and I'm not
saying that Rose was a racist but what
would you do with them so what do you do
then you've got the resource I mean you
could talk about what what troubles me
in it in this whole debate is not you
know let's take a more if you had Hitler
College at Oxford and a statue of Hitler
there wouldn't be any debate about well
I think that's why I think this is a
great development and it's not because
there's a simple answer but the reason
would you do the mobizen I we tell that
story is because I think that as a black
student at Oxford or any elite
educational establishment there's that
is one of the many layers we were I will
not wear anything but I love the attempt
to fight another explanation
there are lots of things you know we
would get ID'd when we went into
colleges you know if I went into a
college with one or more black friends
Oxford we would be asked for university
cards when no one else did one time my
boyfriend came to visit me at my college
and the porter said next time you have
someone who looks like a criminal coming
you need to let us know in advance and
they detained him outside they wouldn't
let him in until I came down and it's
those kind of little acts of micro
aggression that make you feel but you're
in a place that is not set up for you
now I'm not saying that's a reason not
to go and I'm not saying it's not
something you can overcome but as the
black student you know as a university
student you already feel insecure you
know you're under pressure
everybody's questioning whether they're
smart enough or whether they're gonna
make everyone thinks everyone else is
better than them there are so many
pressures and on top of that you know
having a continuing to have a monument
to somebody who I know was responsible
for genocide of the underbelly in what
is now southern Zimbabwe I have no
problem with removing the statue I think
it's very strange that you know you've
still got Rhodes University in South
Africa you've so you've got this legacy
it needs sorting out how would you
rename it and what would you do with the
money because I don't I don't think
anybody sensible would argue once you
know the history of Cecil Rhodes that
country because the issue at the moment
there's not even a comparison there's
anything wrong with the legacy and
that's what I think is useful about this
the former vice-chancellor when this
whole movement really gave a meant him
said if you've got a prom with history
you shouldnt be studying here in the
first place I mean that was his response
there is if there is an issue of about
sort of Year Zero in history we didn't
get on to it but you know renaming
Imperial College you can't pretend that
there wasn't and a British Imperium and
it had some positive aspects but if you
were a victim of the British imperial
effort you it would certainly didn't
look like it now from my perspective I
would like people to study British
imperial history so that you learn what
it's like to be at the bottom of the pie
because that is a really really crappy
place to be that would be you need other
people's ironic it
that we're talking about rewriting
history because the current curriculum
has rewritten it in favor of an
imperialist British supremacist
narrative so for me if you wants to talk
about honesty in the curriculum you need
to start reanalyzing the subject with
the people that are excluded from the
historical narrative even though they
had they made such significant
contributions you know the the figures
that have been elevated despite the fact
that they committed atrocities that are
never talked about you see our recently
renamed a building after a famous
eugenicist you know without me without
any acknowledgement of what his legacy
was and things like that absently
renamed it last year and it's incredible
that these things are still happening
without being without being challenged
and that's what I think is the best
thing about the Rhodes muscle movement
is not that I'm saying that you should
wipe out the Rhodes Scholarship and get
rid of all the funding it's not I'm
saying you should knock down Imperial
and start all over again I just think
that we are at such a low level of
recognition about the truth in our
history that just acknowledging it I
accept all of what you've said and
because I know a lot about Cecil Rhodes
but then a little part of me just think
this is another bunch of whining
students wanting to go into the comfort
room and be protected from scary witches
and Macbeth and I think that that is
part of what has undermined the whole
debate is that whilst in this case there
is an absolutely justified theology if
you like behind it all